hallo
könnt ihr uns heran wenn ja dann
projiziert da passiert was
jetzt bin ich gespannt leute live diese
damen nicht funktioniert aber keiner
guckt zu ich heiße hallo hallo enzi
gaming schreibt hallo da kommen die halo
ja wir haben eben es nicht geschafft
live zu streamen deshalb haben wir bei
facebook gestreamt also wenn ihr das
sehen möchtet wir haben eben schon ganz
viel erzählt auf facebook.com easy
german videos dort findet ihr alles aber
wir wollten noch einmal kurz gruppen ob
es funktioniert und demnächst werden wir
hier bei youtube direct leistungen lilly
schreibt wie geht es ihnen uns geht es
sehr gut immer noch ein besseres bild
als bei facebook oder nicht hallo liebe
leute wir möchten euch nochmal kurz
zeigen und erklären wo wir hinfahren
gerade auch für die youtube zuschauers
viele von euch haben uns geschrieben er
hat uns eingeladen wir fahren im oktober
in die usa und besuchen euch und wir
haben unglaublich viele einladungen
bekommen und auch viele spenden über
unsere indigo kampagne dafür möchten uns
noch mal bedanken und was uns sehr sehr
leid tut und sehr schwer fällt ist dass
wir leider nicht alle einladungen
annehmen können wir haben
sondern auch einladungen bekommen von
schulen und von universitäten die
deutsch unterrichten und wir werden dort
einige schulen besuchen
für ein paar tage unter anderem in
washington dc und in santa barbara und
in diesen orten werden wir auch ein
bisschen länger bleiben deshalb können
wir leider nicht mit dem auto ganz durch
die usa durchfahren sondern wir werden
in new york ankommen werden dann nach
washington dc fan von dort fliegen wir
spiele verkehrt mit dem flugzeug nach
colorado bleiben ein paar tage dort und
fahren von dort aus mit dem auto nach
kalifornien
wenn ihr auf dieser route liegt new york
colorado springs manitou springs
richtung altes national park möchten
zwei fahren dann runter durch monument
valley nach las vegas von dort nach er
nach san francisco zurück nach santa
barbara das ist unsere route wenn ihr
auf der rote wohnt dann drohe dann
schreibt unser laden sein
hier kommen weitere fahren bitte kommen
sie nach hannover
vielleicht bald liebe grüße aus marokko
hallo basmati begrüßt zurück wann kommst
du nach mexiko schreibt was sehen wir
würden sehr gerne nach mexiko kommen
aber leider sind wir noch nicht
eingeladen worden
vielleicht ändert sich das ja in der
zukunft und wir hoffen natürlich dass
wir eines tages mexiko besuchen können
denn wir haben sehr viele zuschauer in
mexiko ist es sehr interessant dass dort
so viele leute auch deutsch lernen
ich liebe youtube live wir auch wenn es
funktioniert lieben wir es natürlich
kari du bist hübsch
nein was sagst du ja mit und ich ja und
ja ich bin ein zuschauer von wisi german
lilly das ist ja eine überraschung dass
da eine zither requisit
wer hätte das gedacht liebe grüße ja
viele grüße aus serbien wir haben immer
wieder viele zuschauer sehr wenn man
serbien janisch ja damals mit dem lkw
und schiff der krieg da los stellt euch
vor bevor jahres videoproduzent wurde
und easy john gründete war lkw fahren
was für eine karriere
warum warum warum warum du tot bist du
weiterhin gefahren ich war im ganzen
noch nicht im osten weil die mauer ist
noch nicht gefallen zu der zeit wo er
dann aber als sie gefallen ist dann bin
ich sehr oft nach aus ostdeutschland und
seht ihr ich habe eine frage an euch
seht ihr video und audio sind krohn bei
uns ist es leicht verzögert deswegen
würde mich das stark interessieren ob
ihr das richtig sehen schreibt mal dazu
bei uns ist es verzehrt aber vielleicht
ja nicht im internet kannst du spanisch
sprechen
apropos quito es prämien karibik in
welcher stadt kann ich maschinenbau
studium in diesem sommersemester
fortsetzen
woher soll ich das gleiche wissen
wolfsburg weil der vg ist oder was da
würde ich sagen musst du mal ich weiß
noch nicht mal wo recherchieren aber
google doch einfach mal das weiß google
besser als ich liebe grüße aus turin
liebe grüße aus afghanistan sah man sah
man guckt uns gerade in afghanistan
wir senden dir ein herz von berlin bis
nach afghanistan
janisch das ist eine wichtige frage von
gust leer
ich habe eine frage wie lange hat
janisch deutsch gelernt wie lange hast
du deutsch gelernt mich zu sagen ich
spreche deutsch von über 30 jahre aber
gelernt ich glaube nach fünf jahren
fühlte ich mich einigermaßen sicher und
diese frage habe ich eben auch bei
facebook bekommen und zwar dort jemand
gefragt wie lange braucht man um deutsch
zu lernen und diese frage hat natürlich
keine antwort denn jeder braucht
unterschiedlich lange ich habe heute
noch mit zwei schülern gesprochen die
sind sechs monate und sieben monate in
deutschland
und sie sprechen schon sehr gut deutsch
noch etwas langsam aber fast also fast
ohne fehler und ich war sehr beeindruckt
davon und ich kenne mittlerweile viele
leute die ein jahr in deutschland sind
und schon sehr fließend deutsch sprechen
also ist es möglich aber es gibt auch
leute diesen 20 jahre in deutschland und
machen immer noch sehr viele fehler es
hängt ein bisschen davon ab ob du
wirklich deutsch lernen willst und wenn
du es willst wenn du richtig richtig
power reinsch text dann schaffst du das
und ich schätze nach ein bis zwei jahren
wirst du sehr fließend und gut deutsch
sprechen auch ein gutes vorlesen
die leute die nicht lesen die werden
natürlich nicht das gelände und sich
nicht fortschritte machen man braucht
man braucht in kontakt mit der sprache
fehlt kommt und wenn du lys sind dass
ein kindle applikation hast zb in einem
smartphone ob die quasi die definition
von den wörtern lieber nicht so stets
durch einfaches antippen von dem wort
willkommen ganz also wenn du dann keine
zeit verlierst für diese wörter
raussuchen
dann gehts super schnell und fair as
schreibt carrey bitte antworte mir mit
dem verb sich anziehen benutzt man im
perfekt haben oder sein es geht beides
und auf den status an ich habe ich habe
mich hingezogen
ich habe mich angezogen aber man kann
auch sagen herangezogen wenn ich
angezogen bin aber wenn ich über die
ganze welt lag das heißt du benutzt nur
habe ich habe mich angezogen wenn ich
erzähle dass ich etwas wenn ich bin
nämlich angezogen
ganz ist sein das ist ja mal was sie hat
genau tschuldigung ich habe quatsch
geredet haben ist die richtige antwort
liebe grüße aus der schweiz carré was
hast du studiert fragt boscolo pro jahr
mit allmähliche geschichte er stimmt
dass es klingt fast wie ein witz es ich
empfehle euch und das letzte in unser
letztlich wie soll daraus handelte da
gibt kann nämlich präsentiert kann ihr
ganzes wissen wächst ein ganzes wissen
aus dem mittelalter von wikipedia also
ich habe auf jeden fall in meinem
studium gelernt wikipedia-artikel
schnell zu lesen und richtig
wiederzugeben
das muss man auch erstmal können ich
habe aber noch etwas studiert ich habe
noch internationale migration und
interkulturelle beziehungen studiert was
mir heute bei meinem beruf weitaus mehr
hilft als mittelalterliche geschichte
aber das habe ich noch nicht
abgeschlossen diesen master werde ich
auch nicht weil ich zu viel zeit auf
youtube verbringe wann soll man da beim
master machen
nach einem jahr
roche das ist bestimmt polnisch oder sz
sz unbedingt bist du polen oder ungarn
nach einem jahr in deutschland haben die
leute bei mir schon nicht mehr gemerkt
dass ich ausländer bin war das ist krass
ich war aber neun als ich
hierhergekommen bin ich hatte also tag
mit der schwarzen okay das relativiert
die ganze geschichte denn wenn man euch
ja ich bin aus polen
wenn man sehr junge hin kommt dann ist
es einfacher und das merke ich auch bei
den menschen die ich kennenlerne
die leute die noch 18 19 sind lernen die
sprache sehr viel schneller als ältere
das nervt mich auch ich lerne leider
nicht so schnell polnisch wie ich das
früher gelernt hätte was denkst du über
berlin idea das ist es was ist das ja
wenn ihr keine frage habt dann sagen
wird es kommen werden 62 zu scheuern ich
hätte das erwartet viel liebe grüße
münchen ihr seid super 8 stefan wenn ich
die hand ganz doll winkelt dann sieht
man sie nicht mehr an verhört stefan
kannst du unsere bitte kurz antworten
ist audio und video synchron das würden
wir gerne von dir wissen wir warten
jetzt auf deine antwort und in der zeit
schweigen wir so ein freund
stefan hat noch nicht geantwortet ja
alles perfekt danke liebe grüße aus
texas grau weiß schreibt michael tanzen
ja liebe grüße nach texas auf jeden fall
von habt ihr eine frage haben sie
belgien schon besucht die amina habe ich
kommst du aus belgien wenn ja aus
welchem ort das würde mich sehr
interessieren
ich habe früher ich habe auch
holländisch studiert und wir haben ein
kurzes nederlandse talent couture in
belgien gemacht und zwar in print und
diese stadt hat mir sehr gefallen ich
habe mich verliebt in diese stadt
es ist eine der schönsten städte in
europa wenn ihr europa besucht fahrt
nach gent in belgien
es ist eine wunderschöne stadt und das
kann ich nur empfehlen also ich war
schon mal in belgien sein muss
bussler schreibt carrey echt hast
polnisch gelernt sagen aber freund oder
cholera im mobilen portals mit morgen
anders ist wenn diese nicht den mobile
pulse co jp morgan chase co jetzt weißt
du bescheid
liebe grüße als sie es los angeles
schreibt gini schied aus hallo wir
besuchen sich demnächst in los angeles
am 25 oktober sind wir in los angeles
vielleicht bist du ja auch da vielleicht
treffen uns ja auch ein bier
ich würde mich sehr freuen das wünsche
ich mir hallo ja bis jetzt kommt die
frage aller fragen hallo hannes stück
kommt aus polen
magst du die musik von frédéric chopin
absolut ja absolut ich höre sie nicht
wirklich aber wenn ich wenn ich die
irgendwo helfe dann denke ich immer was
ist das schöne wunderschöne lorin
schreiben da unheimlich techniker den
wahlen unglaubliche lori lynch treibt
einfach des postillon german have your
say in case you are watching you don't
speak german jetzt das ist bekam
antworten videos and indes videos an
trink westens of the dead in german
which speak low live video das video ist
echt wahnsinn
das in german zurück auf deutsch kennt
ist meine absolute lieblingsstadt ich
komme aus dem niederbayerischen teil
belgiens gutes naja aus dem
niederländischen teil belgiens kennt ist
doch auch im niederländischen teilen
belgiens woher kommst du dein genau nina
lass uns das mal wissen
gut das war ein guter test medi schreibt
carr was denken die deutschen über die
marokkaner
das kann ich dir nicht sagen denn es
gibt ja nicht die deutschen es gibt auch
nicht die marokkaner ich glaube es ist
ein populäres reiseziel in deutschland
und ansonsten kann ich dir nicht so viel
sagen
grüße aus schweden entschuldigung wie
alt bist du und welche sprache sprichst
du carl erik wenk steht ich bin 32 jahre
alt und ich spreche deutsch und englisch
ein bisschen holländisch und nur in
japan gar nicht so viel
ein bisschen französisch 3 das können
wir euch schon mal verraten
wir haben bei easy languages eine neue
serie gestartet das ganze ist die idee
von janosch und zwar wird diese serie
auf deutsch heißen super easy german und
das ganze haben wir schon auf
französisch gemacht ihr könnt mal bei
ebay matches gruppen und das
funktioniert so
wir werden sehr langsam deutsch sprechen
und wir werden sachen zeigen zum
beispiel was ist das das ist ein glas
was ist das lasst mich vergessen mit
artikeln was sehe ich was ich sehe ein
glas ich sehe das glas was ist das das
ist eine festplatte
das ist die festplatte
und so weiter auch der festplatte ist
alles material
hier seht ihr exklusiv eine neue folge
von gls germany lifestyle auf der
festplatte meines ist bat ich hab ihn
die liest bei mir im büro auf dem tisch
seit er in berlin wir sind in berlin und
michael thompson schreibt kochen mit
klaus klaus fehlt mir
uns fehlt klaus auch sie vermissen klaus
so sehr von ganzem herzen vermissen wir
klaus und wir hoffen dass wir bald
wieder kochen klaus wenn du das siehst
wir freuen uns nächstes mal hoffen wir
noch mehr von euch zu sehen und wir
werden wahrscheinlich kw antwortet jetzt
immer live machen weil es einfach sehr
einfach ist und wie es funktioniert und
mehr spaß und ist es spontan spontan
der ton ist fast komplett weg hey guys
from you say when you come into colorado
schreibt wanted adventure nanu wer ist
das denn was dana willkommen am 17
oktober nach colorado bist du dann noch
da
es wäre sehr schön dich zu treffen in
colorado wir haben eine frage an dich
was außer deine hoffnung macht das
bewusstsein so besonders in dem
universum tut mir leid dass man deutsch
so schlecht ist
denn deutsche so streng dass die frage
nicht verstehen lässt uns leid
das darfst du doch nicht sagen du musst
die frage nochmal schreiben andere tom
iannotti
ha ha ha ri bist du schon mal in
skandinavien gewesen nein ich war schon
mal in dänemark aber ich glaube das
zählt nicht ich war noch nie in schweden
noch nie norwegen noch nie in finnland
und ich würde sehr gerne kommen schreibt
mir wohin und ich bin sofort dabei
die einst das einzige problem in
skandinavien ist der alkohol ist teuer
groß klein wenig in deutschland ein
spielfeld sitzen aber ich höre dass die
deutschen nicht so freundlich sind und
das stört mich mein medi das stimmt
nicht die deutschen sind alle sehr
freundlich aber schon sehr freundlich ja
aber die deutschen sind manchmal ein
bisschen verschlossen sie sie können
sich nicht sofort öffnen und sie sind
keine großen meister des small talks das
heißt wenn man einen deutschen auf der
straße trifft zum ersten mal dann sagt
er vielleicht antworten ich es und freue
mich das passiert uns auch wir gehen mit
dem mikrofon auf die straße wir fragen
darf ich ihnen kurz eine frage stellen
und fast einem menschen sagen nein
das die einzige möglichkeit mit den
leuten zu sprechen ist entschuldigung
können sie uns bitte kurz helfen wir
machen einen deutsch sprachkurs helfen
sie uns bitte deutlich zu lernen
dann helfen die leute wenn wir schon
ganz schnell erklären worum es geht ok
könnte dir mal fragen zum thema kulturen
und religionen und das zusammenstellen
wie man sich besser gestalten kann oder
was man von muslimen hält wusstest du
dass jesus ein fisch war
hier ist es war mir ein fisch hat
fischer vermehrt und damit hatte die
menge ernährt um der fisch in der
christlichen symbolik kommt von den
buchstaben unseres buchstaben von jesus
christus
und wenn man das aus griechisch
ausspricht dann eine das an das wort
fisch deshalb diese symbolik hast du
alles weißt ja mit das weiß jedes kind
ist bin ich die frage von anonymous an
ihm kommt jetzt auch englisch sei das
janisch pink jugend consciousness
intelligent intelligence ist special
events that can't go away from what
happens acht episoden die wunderbare
wege nicht speziell sind im grunde sind
sie die die werkzeuge der natur die sich
selbst betrachtet die reflektiert wir
sehen aber wir sehen nicht nur für uns
selber wir würden unsere kultur um uns
führungen damit existieren deshalb sind
wir achten teil
und diese kultur und in dem sinne der
mensch denn der neu geformten der wird
sie der geworden weil er in diese kultur
in das allgemeine bewusstsein der welt
mit hinein geworden sind und
funktioniert innerhalb von davon um das
wie als individualistische feiern das
sollen sie auch fallen das ist wunderbar
aber es ist nicht das wesentliche an
unsere natur die zuschauerzahlen gehen
nach oben seid mit denen sie wirklich
letzteren 30 schreibt was ist dein
lieblings musiker letzte berlin
natürlich einer der absolut größten und
jimi hendrix und nur eine antwort so
eine schwierige frage ich habe leichte
die artikel in deutsch sind die wirklich
so wichtig ja total und das heißt die
damien das ist der allerschlimmste und
alle häufigste fehler dass die menschen
nicht die artikel allzu herum und sie
schreiten immer wieder daran dass sie
jetzt nicht herauskommen das ist das für
ein artikel und es ist nicht so
schwierig erstens es gibt schon jede
menge regel zum beispiel die festplatte
die meisten wörter die auf händen sind
auch die das muss er bitte
verinnerlichen es gibt immer wenn ihr
ein wort lernt lernt ist mit den
artikeln die festplatte die lampe die
frau die decke der tipp für die nächste
frage unbedingt bitte anonymous sagt
denkst vorbehalte die julian schmid das
dann haben wir beim nächsten mal witzig
englisch question laut richtig und jetzt
meine sowie am zusammengearbeitet und
daraus hat sich dann die beziehung fanta
verrat verrat doch nicht alles total
fatale dem festival schreibt viele grüße
hat mir geholfen die sprachprüfung im
februar abzulegen
danke schön solche solche sachen freuen
uns sehr und jetzt kommt meine
lieblingsfrage von am schalter fragt
oder ach ja in welche länder würdet ihr
am liebsten reisen top 3 johanna steiner
top 3
33 chile chile
die mogelei oder muss jetzt hast du
schon drei gesagt so jetzt dass jene
aber mexiko auf jenes also wirklich sehr
schwierig die top 3 zu sagen ich kann
sie auch nicht sagen aber aktuell ist
ändert sich ja immer aktuell
unbedingt will ich nach japan und nach
mali will ich sehr sehr gerne schon sehr
lange wenn dort ja ich glaube jetzt ist
die situation wieder besser aber ich ja
irgendwann will ich auf jeden fall nach
bali reisen und jetzt freuen wir uns auf
die usa aber ich habe auch lust nach
russland zu fahren und mit der
transsibirischen eisenbahn in die
mongolei das ist unser alter also trauen
aber auch aber auch nach mexiko um
eigentlich wollte überall hin dass das
kann man so stehen morgen teile ok super
jemand mir aus japan zu sehen
karim jahr ich liebe euch wirklich ihr
habt mir geholfen deutsch zu lernen
noch eine frage von nina wie wird der
beruf lehrer in deutschland betrachtet
sehr interessante frage
in deutschland bekommen lehrer genau sie
bekommen sehr viel unterstützung vom
staat
sie sind beamte das heißt offiziell
bedienstete des staats und als solche
bekommen sie sehr viele vorteile das
heißt sie bekommen die beste
krankenversicherung sie bekommen sehr
viel geld sie haben quasi immer einen
job
also sie können sie nicht rausreißen sie
können nicht gekündigt werden also im
deutschen staat haben lehrer einen sehr
hohen stellenwert sie sind auch sehr gut
bezahlt und was man damit erreichen
möchte ist dass viele gute leute lehrer
werden oder mehrere wäre ein attraktiver
beruf ist und man sich zum beispiel
leute wie klaus oder martin da
das geklappt gute menschenleeren worden
aber es gibt auch einen negativen aspekt
jahres ja weil sie für dumme mit der
zeit
naja guttenberg nein aber es ist ja auch
so schlechter job nicht installieren ist
es auch so dass natürlich ein beruf der
so attraktiv ist vielleicht auch
manchmal die falschen leute anzieht
nämlich zum beispiel leute die nur
lehrer werden weil sie viel geld
bekommen und weil sie viel sicherheit
haben ja aber das habe ich noch nie
getroffen alle leute gleich solleder
richter geworden sind oder wieder
studieren sind richtig an der fehlt weil
das ist nur meine erfahrung ist alle
leute die ich draußen waren
so richtig mit herzen der wahl 50 50
soll jetzt laufen wir schon mit einer
halbe stunde
wir müssen jetzt diesen live stream
beenden wir sagen tschüss liebe leute
ich weiß nicht wie man das macht aber
ich klicke jetzt einfach irgendwas und
vielleicht sind weg danke fürs zuschauen
wir haben uns gefreut über all eure
kommentare und wir machen weiter freitag
18 uhr unseren offiziellen zweiten oder
ersten live stream
kari antwortet live wir freuen uns schon
auf eure fragen bis bald liebe grüße aus
berlin
ich hab mich kannst du noch einmal
zeigen bitte damit die leute wirklich
sehen dass wir hier sind
bitte einmal den das fenster auf
es ist sehr viel action fordert er jetzt
gerade ist nichts los
da kommt die tram das geht einfach vor
der tür sind jeden tag kreuels die bei
uns fährt ihr vorbeigehen und saufen
beine zu schauen und bis bald
das natürlich jetzt um die übertragung
an